hey there townscapers happy thanksgiving
and welcome back to my channel
if this is your first time here i want
to give you a big welcome and thank you
so much for coming today please do me a
favor
hit the like button subscribe and share
this video with other people if you
think they would enjoy it
that way this will help me out a lot and
i really appreciate it today is a really
big day not only is it turkey day but
oscar released a new update
today he gifted us with lighthouses and
this is something that many townscapers
alike have wanted
and i'm really excited about it they're
really easy to make and i'll show you
how
for the record mr stahlberg says that
they do not light up yet that is
something that he has to work on he
specifically stated that he has not
figured out how to make a lighthouse
light
um so that it fits the style and it
works on wicker devices as well
so do give him some time and i'm sure
he'll work it out i'm really excited
about that though
um so anyways we'll just get into it the
trick is the last three blocks of a
narrow tower have to be different colors
and you can make different variations of
these towers they can be in different
colors
but you have to make sure that the last
three blocks are different colors or
it's not going to turn into a lighthouse
uh you can put it on different types of
structures
you can even put it on a crane which i
thought was pretty cool
and that's it it's pretty simple so you
know you can go out there and you can
make lighthouses for your builds and you
can really put lighthouses on peninsulas
and put them on tall tall towers and
stuff like that and make some really
really colorful nautical builds and just
do some really cool stuff out there
but anyways that's it for me i just
wanted to come out and show you guys
this really really quick update that i
thought was amazing
um please stay safe please be careful
out there and have a happy thanksgiving
and i'll see y'all next time